Oh,
it's my pleasure to introduce Elizabeth Rozner.
She's here today to speak about her most recent book survivor cafe,
the legacy of trauma and a labyrinth of memory.
It grapples with intricate and possibly unanswerable questions,
but how we recognize and cope with the traumas we inherit and how we can
properly keep alive the personal stories behind grid historical atrocities even
after everyone who lived through that and it's gone and her focus on Holocaust
survivors.
Rosner uses the lens of for three visits to Germany with her father who was born
in Hamburg and imprisoned in Brooklyn,
valid concentration camp.
The book also investigates the multigenerational aftermath of the bombings of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
the Cambodian killing fields,
the legacies of slavery,
and other historical atrocities.
I could read from any one of dozens of endorsements for this book,
but I'll choose one from the San Francisco Chronicle,
which name survivor cafe want to be a hundred best books of 2017 survivor cafe
feels like the book Rosner was born to ride.
Each page is imbued with urgency,
with sincerity,
with heartache,
with heart.
Her words,
alongside the words of other survivors of atrocity and their descendants across
the globe can help us build a more humane world.
Prior to survivor cafe,
Elizabeth published three bestselling novels,
the first of which the speed of light was internationally acclaimed and
translate it into nine languages.
Its central theme addresses the effects of the Holocaust and the descendants of
survivors.
A graduate of Stanford,
UC Irvine,
and the University of Queensland in Australia.
Elizabeth is awesome.
My aunt,
I had the opportunity to accompany her on the third of the trips to Germany with
my grandfather after which she started putting pen to paper on survivor cafe.
Without further ado,
Elizabeth Rosner.
Thank you.
As raw.
You forgot to introduce yourself.
That was Ezra Brittler,
my nephew and employee of Google.
It's great to be here.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you for spending lunchtime with me.
My hope today is that I will share with you some of what I think of as the
highlights of what I learned while writing this book.
It's a blending of the personal narrative as as ray mentioned,
my,
my role in life in a way as a daughter of two Holocaust survivors.
Please help yourselves to books as you come in there for you and um,
and that then led me to reaching into a wider research based approach to other
lineages that seemed to carry residue from historical trauma.
And as we mentioned,
a few of them I'll touch on.
I'll touch on some of them in my talk and I also am going to share with you some
things that we are learning in the realm of science about measurable evidence
based studies showing that trauma actually modifies the expression of DNA and
that what we have long known as anecdotally children,
grandchildren,
great grandchildren of people who have endured war and genocide and other acts
of violence,
that that residue seems to pervade subsequent generations.
Scientists in the field of genetics,
a new field actually called epigenetics,
is starting to show that this is not something we're just imagining that it's
actually present and measurable.
Then I'm going to touch on some of the impacts of memory studies and the ways
that we memorialize the past that also relate to how,
not just personal inheritance of trauma,
but the collective inheritance of trauma can be addressed in terms of culture,
in terms of shared memory,
and ultimately in the hope of healing and transforming some of those legacies
into something more hopeful and in order we hope not to continue to repeat a lot
of the atrocities of the past.
So to start with,
um,
a little bit about me,
I,
um,
I grew up in upstate New York.
Both of my parents,
um,
as I mentioned were Holocaust survivors.
My mother was in the Vilna ghetto,
which you may be familiar with historically,
and then she survived the war in hiding with her parents in the Polish
countryside.
As a young teenager,
my father,
as you also heard,
um,
was imprisoned in the bullhorn walled concentration camp at the age of 15.
And the camp was liberated just after he turned 16 years old.
My parents ended up meeting as refugees in Sweden,
getting married in Israel and then coming to America.
And by the time I was born on the very last day of the fifties it was as though
I were being born into the other life that my parents had created their American
selves.
They're reinvented selves,
and yet I really did feel as though something had been transmitted to me in
utero and for a long time,
people like me,
children of Holocaust survivors were told that we were being hysterical or too
sensitive about feeling as though our emotional landscape,
our psychological landscape was so impacted by something that didn't happen to
us.
But in fact,
as I mentioned,
we are starting to recognize that this is a real phenomenon.
So I became a writer partly because I kept on wanting to ask questions.
You've probably heard that writers are encouraged to write what they know will.
In my case,
I wanted to write what I wanted to know.
So writing for me has always been an active curiosity and inquiry and
investigation.
And this book,
even though it comes after three novels and a poetry collection in many ways,
really does feel like the book that contains all of the questions I've been
asking all of my life.
What is it that I carry that happened before I was born?
How does that not differentiate me from others but actually make me feel even
more connected to others?
When I was growing up,
I often felt like I was markedly different from my peers.
A lot of the Americans in my hometown had been there for generations.
I was a first generation American,
as was my older sister and my younger brother,
so we had something in common with each other and our small kind of tribe.
My parents' friends,
a lot of them were also survivors of the Holocaust in Europe,
but in the larger sense,
I didn't feel like I was much like my peers.
And so over time I started to recognize that the more I looked into what I felt
made me so unusual that I felt so sensitive to let's say,
anxieties or preparing for catastrophe.
Or there were some friends of mine I know whose parents also survived going into
exile from the Holocaust.
They always kept a suitcase packed just in case things like that,
that we considered normal.
Most of our friends thought that was a little bizarre,
a little paranoid maybe,
or a little overreactive over sensitive.
And yet over time I became more and more clear that in fact,
subsequent generations of Japanese who survived Hiroshima and Nagasaki actually
have some similar behavior patterns and thought patterns.
So do the descendants of slaves,
excuse me,
African American slaves in the United States.
So do refugees from Cambodia who survived the killing fields in Cambodia.
And unfortunately the list does go on.
Um,
it's a big list.
And in the book I don't cover every atrocity because in fact,
the more research I did,
the more I realized that even in the news,
as I was writing the book,
new atrocities were taking place.
So I don't for example,
include what's happening to the Rohingya in Myanmar even though that is in this
moment,
a genocide unfolding before our eyes.
Um,
so the conversation is a big one and what I'm trying to do is allow you some
intimate access to a personal story and then see how you might find your own
connection to that story even if you don't necessarily recognize any of the
places I've referred to,
but your own family lineage is probably inscribed with something that does then
pass through you.
Intergenerationally
I'm going to read you a passage from one of the psychiatrists that I cite in my
book who specializes in inherited trauma.
She works with families whose children seem to be exhibiting signs of PTSD even
when the children themselves have not been traumatized.
And this is the great mystery that we've been trying to understand.
How is it that you can look at somebody who grew up seemingly in a safe and
protected environment,
still be displaying signs of PTSD.
So I'm going to read you her,
her definition of how,
how this PTSD shows up.
Unresolved trauma takes two different forms.
The first is dissociation,
where the trauma is blocked.
There are no words not only pushed away but insecurely pushed away.
And just to explain about that a little bit.
So,
so this kind of numbing effect,
this way of sort of not being present in the moment is is for some people a form
of PTSD and inability to manage their emotions is so overwhelming that they just
shut down completely emotionally.
The second way,
the opposite way is where the trauma is uncontainable overflowing.
Interactions are overflowing with emotion.
The person mixes past and present the trauma intrudes in places it doesn't
belong and that's the sentence I really want to focus on.
The trauma intrudes on places it doesn't belong.
It's sometimes defined as people's inability to feel safe in a safe environment.
So you may know someone or have witnessed someone or experienced it yourself
sitting in a perfectly quiet place out in nature perhaps where everything seems
to be completely tranquil and unthreatening and yet your heart is racing your
pulses going mad.
You might break out in a sweat.
These are signs that internally you're experiencing,
not what the present moment is offering up,
but some associative experience that makes you feel as though you're not in the
present.
You're actually in some other past may be experiencing things that were handed
to you by parents or even grandparents.
So I'm going to try to define epigenetics,
you briefly and to say first of all that I'm not a scientist.
And so sometimes people object to the concept of epigenetics as though,
um,
they want to take issue with it and you're welcome to look it up and do your own
research.
I'm not the person who has done the research.
I'm citing the research.
So at,
it began with mice at Atlanta University,
I mean Emory university in Atlanta,
a group of geneticists took some pre adolescent mice and expose them to the
scent of Cherry Blossom,
which is a chemical compound and an electric shock.
So the mice quickly learned to associate that scent with fear,
panic,
and pain.
So even when the shock was no longer present,
they would get extremely agitated when these mice produced offspring.
Now remember they were pre adolescent.
So none of these mice was pregnant.
There were no baby mice in utero.
Three and four generations of mice.
Later when those mice were exposed to cherry blossom for the first time,
they panicked.
They acted as if they already knew the associate of pain that they might
receive.
They'd never witnessed their ancestry mice being exposed to the scent or the
shock.
So these researchers concluded that something had shifted in the DNA that was
being passed to them.
Now the DNA itself wasn't necessarily being modified.
It was epigenetically meaning something on top of the,
of the DNA on the gene was being modified and they call that the expression of
the gene.
Sometimes cortisol levels,
which are associated with stress hormone that we produced to help us respond to
stress was either suppressed or exaggerated.
At the same time that those studies with mice were going on,
there were researchers in Israel looking at Holocaust survivor families and
noticing something similar that grandchildren,
great grandchildren of Holocaust survivors were coming in for therapy with
symptoms of PTSD for trauma that they themselves have not lived through.
And so they started to connect the dots between these studies and they,
the studies are small,
humans don't reproduce as quickly as mice.
So we don't know yet how residual,
how long lasting these effects are.
But notable enough for people to raise questions and,
and encourage more studies to be done to look into this.
So it turns out that for example,
Cambodian refugees living in the United States are coming into therapeutic
contexts with about a 95% rate of PTSD and the community off the charts high in
Cambodia,
it's estimated somewhere between one out of four and one out of every three
Cambodians was murdered by the Camaro Rouge.
Monumental portions of the population were impacted not only by the losses but
by the fear associated with those losses.
The reign of terror that lasted for the years,
the Khmer Rouge were empower.
And you can sort of do the math yourself.
These numbers need to be looked at.
So what's happening in the United States right now I think is pretty strong
evidence that we have unresolved trauma throughout the country.
We have unresolved legacies of racism,
slavery,
Jim Crow laws,
you name it,
lynching.
The aftermath of lynching in a community has never fully been addressed.
And we are seeing what it looks like when we don't address trauma,
when we don't address the residue of trauma in Japan.
They also have similar investigations into these lineages of the survivors of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
who,
for example,
were often completely silent on the subject.
They're radiation exposure was so severe that they feared that if their children
were known to be the offspring of people who had been exposed to radiation,
no one would want to marry them because of fear of birth defects.
So there was a long history of silence about the effects of those bombs and the
fallout,
the literal fallout.
We use fallout now as a metaphor,
but it was literal.
It's still his literal.
So a lot of what I'm talking about in my book is actually this interconnection
between literal residue,
literal lasting radioactivity in the body and what that means metaphorically,
that we do carry the effects of what happened to our ancestors and our cultural
companions,
our compatriots.
So
what,
what that leads me then to consider is how do we do this memory together?
How do we remember not just what happened in my family.
For example,
my nephew introduced this story of three different trips I took to Germany with
my father,
one in 1983 one in 1995 and the third in 2015 so in 1983 I was in my twenties my
father was in his 50s and Germany was still divided.
So when we went first to Hamburg,
then to Berlin to pass through checkpoint Charlie to get permission to enter
into East Germany and visit site of the camp.
What we were facing was a culture,
a country that was choosing to remember the past in a particular way.
They're historical version of what had happened in World War II,
focused primarily on the victory for them of communism over fascism.
When we tried to visit the site of the concentration camp,
we were directed away from the camp itself to a monument located a couple of
kilometers away that had victorious communist statues celebrating their victory
over the fascists.
Jews were not part of the conversation.
So my father and I did find our way to the side of the camp.
There was nobody there.
We were the only two people there.
It was this vast barren field of gravel,
still surrounded by barbed wire and guard towers,
but nobody inside them.
So that was my first experience of feeling the presence of those ghosts and the
fact that I could share this with my father in such a way that literally,
literally we both heard in the wind the sound of people screaming at the same
time.
And for me that was a palpable sense in my body.
That's something my father had lived through,
was really passing into my body.
And at the end of that trip he said,
I want to come back with the rest of the family.
I had begun writing about,
I was becoming a writer.
And of course my material seems so obvious.
My family's story was my material.
So flash forward 12 years later to 1995 and now my siblings and I,
my mother and my father are all going to the reunified Germany together
and Brooklyn Bald is now the center of a commemoration site.
Um,
it was being celebrated with a feast,
a banquet on the site of the concentration camp.
A completely surreal event that I write about in the book.
I felt like Fellini had filmed this.
It was just bizarre,
a giant tent on the site of this place where so many people were starved and
work to death and murdered.
And right in the middle of the meal,
one of my father's front teeth fell out and suddenly he looked,
have you ever seen someone with a missing front tooth?
You know,
this whole suddenly appearing in his smile and his face.
And I was remembering in that experience that when we had been there in 1983
together,
he passed a kidney stone while we were there.
So you can see how the body has its own way of remembering trauma and re
experiencing revisiting trauma.
So now the context was Germany was reunified.
They were trying to re organize their memory literally of how they were
remembering what had happened during World War II.
20 years later,
2015 my nephew and I and my father are all in the same place.
Now.
We're three generations together and we are being echoed and met by three
generations of Germans,
especially the grandchildren who call themselves like the Jewish,
you know,
um,
compartment of generation of survivors.
Third generation they call themselves three g.
That's how I found out I was two g because my three g nephew explained to me
that I was now a member of this second generation.
The grandchildren of the survivors and the grandchildren of the Nazis were now
taking it upon themselves to remember together what had happened.
So there was this remarkable bridge across the great divide of history to say
it's our obligation to remember this together and to look at our counterparts as
fellow travelers through this journey of what part of the past is still
impacting us.
Now in the present
in Japan,
something similar is happening.
The first,
second and third generation survivors of Hiroshima and Nagasaki are also asking
themselves,
how do we keep this memory alive?
And I mentioned a little while ago that this memory is both personal and
collective,
even if you're not personally related to the survivors.
How do we all carry this in a shared way?
And in Japan there's a remarkable role being taken on by people who call
themselves den Shosha,
um,
which is translated as the designated transmitter of memory and the den Shosha
are memorizing the stories of the survivors of Hiroshima and Nagasaki so that
they can tell the story when the firsthand experience is no longer available in
person.
They are literally choosing to embody the story and humanize it,
keep it individual and meaningful in that way.
So what are some other parallels for that?
Well,
in South Africa,
you probably know after apartheid ended,
they create Mandela and others created something called the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission where they chose to coordinate the remembering of the
past,
not in a legal punishing a format,
but in a way of creating dialogue.
And conversation,
allowing the victims of apartheid to speak to the perpetrators and be heard.
Simply have their stories be told as the truth because one of the first things
that goes in war and atrocities and genocide is truth itself.
The facts,
I am afraid we're witnessing a lot of this right now in our culture when facts
are becoming distorted and the truth seems blurry at the edges,
blurry at best.
So in Rwanda where there was also a horrific genocide in the late 1990s when
800,000 Tutsis were murdered by their Hutu neighbors with machetes informance
800,000 people murdered in a period of four months.
Now the Rwandan government is trying to help the remaining Hutus and the
remaining Tutsis work together to rebuild the country as neighbors.
They were neighbors before the genocide.
They are neighbors again.
How does this work?
How can you bring victims and perpetrators together in a way that isn't
retraumatizing?
Well,
it's complicated.
When I was revising survivor cafe.
Every time I wrote about something like this,
I would go back over the book again and again my last time to reread it.
I looked for the word complicated.
I did a word search for complicated.
It showed up 49 times.
I had to go back through and really consider the nuances of that word,
but everything I was talking about was indeed complicated.
The complication of how many generations past slavery in America are we,
and yet we are still bearing witness to the unresolved trauma that it left
behind.
Bryan Stevenson,
who is an African American lawyer who used to be with the southern poverty law
center and started something called the equal justice initiative,
has been determined to create monuments in every location where a lynching took
place in Europe.
Something similar had been done is being done and artists put down what he
called stolper Steiner stumbling stones,
replacing individual cobblestones with gilded over stones,
stamped with the name of a person who was murdered and they say,
here lived this person's name,
this person birthdate,
and died in Auschwitz.
Treblinka,
Robin's Brooke,
my Donek,
the names of camps,
the names of maybe unknown locations.
So Bryan Stevenson said the power of standing on a spot where you know,
an atrocity took place has to be replicated in the United States where these
lynching sites were.
Thousands of people witnessed lynchings in America.
It wasn't just the horrific violence done to the individual.
There was an act of violence committed in full view of often the entire town.
So how do we remember that in a way that honors the victim and tells the truth
about what happened?
So plaques are being placed in locations where lynchings took place and a big
museum in Montgomery is,
is being built with soil from each of those places to be held in jars and
vessels to say,
we are all connected by this earth that we stand on.
So even though I might be tempted to say my ancestors weren't slave owners,
I'm a first generation American.
I don't have to take responsibility for the residue of this trauma simply by
being an American standing on American soil.
I do have to take responsibility for what happened in this country.
And that I'm the beneficiary of a lot of things that we all benefited from
during slavery and all of the inhuman violence committed against post slavery
Americans.
So how do we remember,
well,
how do we,
how do we work carefully to preserve this memory and to keep it personal,
as I said,
and also to keep it alive once the witnesses and the people who enacted those
crimes or were the victims of those crimes are no longer here to remind us of
the human experience.
So I don't know how many of you have ever been to Washington DC,
the US Holocaust museum in Washington DC and also the very recently completed
African American Museum of history and culture.
Anybody?
Have you been there?
Both astonishingly important institutions?
I really recommend that you visit them and they each tell a story,
a narrative that is meant to engage you physically in the process of memory.
So at the Holocaust museum,
when you enter the museum,
you're conducted to an elevator taken up to the top floor.
And when you step out of the elevator,
the first thing you see is a photograph of American soldiers.
Looking down at a pile of corpses that they encountered when they arrived at a
concentration camp in Europe in April of 1945 now,
what I realized when I went to that museum and saw that image was that this is
the American version of that story.
My version growing up,
as I told you was before I even knew what I knew.
I knew that something horrible had happened to my parents in Europe that
involved images and situations that I was now seeing Americans encountered and
thought,
oh,
now we understand.
But of course there's a whole story that has to be revisited in order to
understand what they were seeing for the first time.
So then you work your way through the museum,
finding out everything that took place that led to that moment,
but it's still an American frame around a story.
I think that's really important to understand that museums as fact based as they
can be our framing a narrative.
So what's happening now in the south where they're talking about what should we
do with confederate statues is a question about who gets to frame the narrative.
Do we keep the statues there because they signify a civil war that really did
take place in America?
Well,
don't we need context around them?
Don't we need to know that they were defending something that we now consider to
be completely important?
It wasn't just,
Oh,
the north one in the south lost it was that they were diametrically opposed
ideologies,
one of which believed that you were entitled to own other people.
That was a wrong ideology.
So for us to say,
well,
there were just two different ideologies is I think an affront to the victims,
right?
So now there's this debate about what kind of structure or museum can we put
these confederate statues inside of.
So a fuller story gets told about who they were,
what they meant,
and,
and they were on the wrong side of history,
basically.
So the African American Museum of history and culture,
interestingly to me,
takes,
uh,
the other approach from this Holocaust museum,
top down,
descent into the past.
The African American museum starts with the past underground.
You start down below in this museum and you read and enter into the centuries of
the slave trade,
a lot of which was based on sugar.
So I'll let you think about that for a moment.
Sugar,
the demon.
So you climb through this lower portion of the story and you work your way up
through slavery in America,
the civil war followed by Jim Crow,
the civil rights movement,
and finally at the very top of the museum in this incredible celebratory way,
you get to experience the beautiful and significant contributions of African
Americans to American culture,
music,
dance,
theater,
language,
fashion,
everything,
language,
hip hop,
the vernacular expressed through architecture and movement,
all of which shows that the bones that lie underground have still somehow
managed to produce this incredible resilience and beauty and transformation.
So weirdly,
I decided to start that museum at the top.
I think I saw all the crowds going down and I wanted to be different.
And I started at the top and I'll tell you,
it was hard to leave that floor.
It was so full of wonder and joy and celebration and innovation and creativity.
But then I remembered that I had to see what was buried under that.
I had to see what was in the soil that gave birth to that.
And it reminded me that we don't just inherit the trauma of our ancestors.
We inherit the resiliency of our ancestors.
We inherit the perseverance of our ancestors and the will to go on and the will
to create a new life in a new place like my parents did,
like maybe many of your parents or grandparents did.
So,
um,
I want to leave you with,
with a couple of questions about consciousness with language consciousness,
with how we use our words.
So I don't know how many of you react to language the way I do,
but for example,
when I hear the words ethnic cleansing,
the phrase ethnic cleansing,
which we heard
during the eruptions in Bosnia,
when you get Slavia was falling apart and the Serbs were trying to ethnically
cleanse
the Christians out of the Serbian held territories,
there was a big outcry about what a euphemism that phrase was that ethnic
cleansing was essentially a coverup for genocide and mass murder.
Do you remember?
It's come back into our vocabulary again.
The New York Times is referring to what's happening in Myanmar as ethnic
cleansing and sometimes they put quotation marks around it and sometimes they
don't.
And to me this seemingly normalized version of that phrase is saying something
about how we have accepted propaganda terms into our vocabulary as if they are
descriptive rather than
propaganda.
So chain migration is another phrase.
There is debate about the use of the phrase chain migration.
If you're not aware of it,
look into it.
The idea that people who are legally immigrated into America and want to bring
family and relatives.
Now that phrase chain migration is being used again in a propaganda stick way to
hear these echoes of,
I hear slavery,
I hear chains of you know,
poverty of lower class relationships of illegal activity,
all of these evocations that this language produces,
we need to question.
So instead of using these phrases automatically,
I recommend that we use the phrase family unification or read a unification
instead of chain migration.
It's actually more accurate.
It's equally descriptive.
It's more accurately descriptive than chain migration instead of ethnic
cleansing.
Genocide is the more appropriate term.
Mass murder is the more appropriate term.
Why did these words matter?
Because they impact our ways of thinking about the world.
They impact how we see one another.
The assumptions we make.
Do you remember when the photograph of the drowned Syrian child was appeared
everywhere?
One of the victims of a drowning off the coast of Greece.
There are millions of refugees in flight for their lives.
That one photograph of a drowned child was a way of saying to people,
don't forget this is happening to one person at a time.
When you call people immigrants,
it's different than when you call them refugees.
The emotional content is really different in those two terms.
Doesn't,
don't you feel your heart and more likely to open toward a refugee than toward
an immigrant who the implication being,
oh,
they just come are coming here because they want better opportunities.
They,
I should say we are coming here for better opportunities,
but refugee means,
oh,
someone who has no choice.
Someone who's in flight for his or her life or the life of their extended
family.
So language matters because it impacts how we think and feel about human lives,
about human lack of choice,
about humans and exile about humans who are suffering.
So for me,
all of this research was a way of saying to myself,
what I grew up with didn't just teach me that I was carrying a particular
burden.
It taught me that I have a responsibility to be empathetic toward those who
suffer too.
Whether I know their full story or not,
whether I know how many generations back the suffering goes or not,
but that each individual actually has some kind of legacy of sorrow,
of loss,
of harm,
of pain.
And it may be vast,
it may be on the scale of Cambodia,
one out of three or four people in the entire country murdered by the Camaro
Rouge.
It might be on a smaller scale,
but it doesn't matter the scale.
What matters is the personal level of identification and that willingness to say
we are connected by what we carry.
And we can recognize that in one another through our language,
through our storytelling,
through our collective forms of memory in museums or institutions or
installations,
like a stone placed on a sidewalk saying this was a person who lived here and
was murdered.
So if I may,
um,
before I open it up to your questions,
which I really welcome and invite questions or comments,
I want to leave you with an image and it's a Japanese term and a Japanese art
form that I think is,
again,
a beautiful metaphor for all that I've been talking about today.
Can Sugi is sometimes translated as golden repair,
but I've recently seen it translated as the art of embracing damage or the art
of precious scars,
the art of embracing damage,
the art of precious scars.
So imagine a precious bowl,
a piece of pottery that was handed down to you or something you made or
something you paid a lot of money for and it shatters,
cry,
throw it away.
You have a lot of choices.
Replace it with a new perfect one.
Kim Sugie says,
you fill in the cracks with gold.
You repair it in such a way as to enhance and identify more fully where the bowl
has been broken and how in healing it and putting the pieces back together.
You see all of its history.
You see the damage it went through and is still not just hold,
but in fact more beautiful than it was before.
So the damage that we carry doesn't have to be looked at as loss or pain that
will never go away,
that will never heal from.
But neither does it mean that we're trying to make it go away and erase it so
that we never have to look at it again.
The truth is we have ongoing damage every day,
all the time to our bodies,
our psyches,
our culture,
our truth,
our story.
So this image for me is so,
so resonant of an option.
We have to hold our damage,
um,
delicately,
lovingly and to let it be seen to say I am not only the the pain and the loss
that have happened to me,
but I'm also filled with something even more precious and more beautiful,
which is the restoration of self.
And ultimately I hope an image like this is an indication of what we're capable
of as human beings.
That we can,
a wholeness that doesn't keep repeating the separations and the murders and the
hatreds but rebuilds a culture that is based on something collective and
connected
and healing.
I hope so.
Thank you for listening to me.
I really hope that you'll make sure to take a book to take with you to read and,
and consider,
but I would love to know if you have any questions right now or comments.
Yes,
you're not to leave.
When we pass away our body and returns with dust and the spirit persists by all
the memories,
all the experiences actually persist.
Not,
let me use a technical term like cloud.
Imagine all those memories safe,
even cloud and the younger generation has a different generation can access that
piece of it made mission.
Using a token password from the cloud that could explain the different
generations may be able to be on the same traumatic experience and somehow you
just persist throughout the generations.
I love it when I think about it is that I love it.
I think it's,
um,
it's a brilliant interweaving of,
of our technological understanding of how data is,
is saved and this human data,
this data of memory.
My father actually,
who thankfully is still alive,
he's going to be 89 in April,
has often said to me,
I wish there was a way that all of my knowledge that I've gained over all of
these years of living and learning could be stored somewhere and saved so that
it can be passed on.
What a shame that it can't be saved.
And so he's envisioning this giant brain download,
you know,
but as you say,
it's spirit too.
It's not just what we hold in our minds and our bodies.
There's something that we don't quite know what it is or how it operates.
Young talked about this too young,
envisioned your cloud as well when he talked about the collective unconscious
and that what we carry ancestrally shows up in our dreams sometimes.
I know a woman whose mother was also in a concentration camp and this woman has
dreams that when she tells her mother about them,
her mother says,
you dreamed something that happened to me.
How is that possible that a dream could be transmitted?
Well this is the kind of thing that I think you've just described that it's all
being stored somewhere and that we are I that at birth,
that token that you just mentioned are birth is,
is our past key to access.
That brilliantly said.
Thank you for sharing that.
Any other questions or comments please?
Sorry,
that microphone is so far away,
right?
I noticed that most of the examples you gave were like large,
uh,
large scale societal things like the Holocaust or slavery and wondering if you
think the same idea as you presented applied to like smaller things like
individual trauma or maybe like what I have in mind.
I think like mass shootings.
Absolutely.
Thank you for that question.
I think that I do in the book talk about nine 11,
um,
which of course as a country we thought of as happening to all of us,
but we know that in actual fact it happened to,
you know,
two buildings in New York City and the Pentagon.
We know that in theory anyway,
it was a limited number of victims.
But what we recognize is that the entire country does still feel the
reverberations of that event.
So I don't know if that's an example of what you're talking about,
but I also think the me too movement right now is evidence of something very
similar.
Women and young girls who've all experienced some form of sexual assault,
sexual violence,
sexual abuse,
one by one individual stories begin to emerge as a way of experience that lasted
not just for generations,
but millennia in a way.
So the connection I think between the individual experience and the bigger story
is present.
Whenever there's an individual trauma that,
um,
I don't go into this in the book.
Again,
like I said,
I had to choose what I included,
but I know for example,
in the,
in the gay community,
especially in the community of people who were exposed to aids in the,
in the eighties and nineties,
that there's actually a syndrome that is referred to as aids survivor syndrome.
That people who lived and had all of their friends die all around them but
didn't die for whatever reason,
we're still trying to study.
Why did,
uh,
very few people who were HIV positive not succumb to aids,
they have this experience of,
am I fortunate or am I hugely unfortunate that I've lost everyone?
I loved that I witnessed everyone's death and dying all around me.
So that's another example.
Also just um,
individual experiences of a suicide in the family that can feel certainly like
an ongoing trauma in a family and then an individual might look back at
multigenerational patterns in the family and see,
oh,
each generation had a suicide.
What does that mean?
We're just starting to understand this.
There's another term you might come across in addition to epigenetics.
It's an acronym,
Ac ease,
adverse childhood experiences and pediatricians and educators are starting to
come up with a tool for measuring when they meet a young child and the child is
acting out behavior early in school or not wanting to go to school or they're
crazy things going on with the kid.
They'll ask the kid how many of these things or they will ask an adult related
to the kid,
how is there,
is there poverty in the home?
Is there someone incarcerated in the family?
Is there mental illness in the family?
Is there homelessness in the family?
And they calibrate and quantify these adverse childhood experiences and say a
score of such and such is likely to lead to mental illness,
health problems,
early death.
So we're trying to intervene at younger and younger ages now to recognize how
even individual traumas reverberate throughout a culture and a system.
Yeah,
I hope that it,
does that answer your question?
Thank you.
Other questions?
Not so much in a question.
A comment is more than welcome to.
Yes,
please.
Oh,
I'm gonna ask you that.
Um,
all,
um,
what I actually see is that if 15 hundreds,
uh,
Japan in bed,
Korea and they to thousands of a craftsman before dead,
um,
most of the bad word.
And so when I ended up,
and I hate to be,
see that powder it in Brooklyn,
um,
I see,
the history where that actually came from.
So we only see that as a sign up at conciliation,
but that itself,
um,
match the Hess,
he then set history behind you.
And then you,
I should've mentioned Austin.
Yeah.
Uh,
the serves,
uh,
when he was going around,
there was a newspaper article have maybe long time ago,
uh,
in serve yet there's actually a museum where one of the things that was the
speeding the vizio is something that looks like a tuning fork.
A tuning fork has a new shape.
Um,
Syrian people actually headbutt tuning fork because before,
uh,
the Bosniaks we're actually gals,
you'd be eyes up the service,
you just can get boring.
So when we actually see a history of genocide,
um,
it actually goes deeper.
It's not just okay,
it serves are awesome guys.
There's deep history of a vicious cycle that they went on.
And so we don't get to see a lot of big inspiration throughout the history.
Um,
my recollection of the only history of reconciliation was,
uh,
when I started recording Nelson Mandela,
being interviewed after he is prison release.
Well,
as one of the first things that he said was,
I forget,
and Ben,
they don't only use,
made me jump out of a chair because that's something totally unexpected,
but that actually gave hope to the future of South Africa.
They're black people coming for the lack of better term.
I'm not your back.
People coming into power in South Africa wasn't going to be that bad because
here's the fighter who resisted apartheid for such a long time and put on their
how spreads and RSN prison life was coming out and saying that he actually
forgive those perpetrators and he's active,
willing to work with them or better future.
Unfortunately,
those are rare occurrences in history.
And now what I'm seeing is that,
um,
I hear news about,
Syria where people like die Stephen,
they're inside of dying.
And I hear about a Yemen where,
uh,
there's a proxy war going on between Saudi Arabia and Saudi Arabia and Iran and
even in the states.
Um,
I like to travel,
but probably the last place I want to travel these problem that Alabama hair
people are,
we're actually rooting for Roy and war in this present day and age.
Yeah.
And so I have three kids.
I want to leave a better future for my kids.
But at the same time,
you know,
I wonder is that word getting any better has history,
Palestinian lessons,
where do we,
you know,
and this fissure say,
well,
how can uh,
contribute,
uh,
and seeming the I'm in the minority and my voice is I drawn down.
It's like,
how do I reconcile it?
And I was actually coming to the pet dog two here.
Um,
a little bit of maybe I was hoping for some sort of a clue as to how you are
able to find the closest to the risk and station between the Germans and the
Nazis.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't mean to cut you off.
We're running out of time.
I want to say you do have a voice.
Your voice is really powerful in what you've just been saying.
And I do think that Mandela is a beautiful example.
A rare example.
Forgiveness is not necessarily something that can be flipped like a switch.
It's incredibly rare that somebody can even privately make a statement like
that.
Um,
but Germany is an amazing exemplar right now are a model country in taking
responsibility for their history and preserving it even when it shows them in
their worst light.
And that,
that gives me hope,
right?
That Germans aren't saying bygones,
let it be,
let it be considered history.
And we are no longer obligated to remember.
There was a time when German said that,
and there are definitely still Germans who say that.
So I can't speak for every German who's committed to this to this honest
pathway.
But reconciliation is a goal and it's very difficult to achieve.
And forgiveness,
I don't even know if that is a goal so much as a form of justice.
There's,
there's retribution and there's restoration,
right?
So retribution is more where people want to take revenge and see punishment
meted out and rest door.
Restorative justice is more a way of saying let's at least have the truth be
told and that's where you begin.
And if forgiveness eventually arises as a result,
that's good,
but not necessary.
Maybe.
So,
um,
the,
the complications in Asia,
the complications in Africa,
there's a whole colonial legacy underneath all of that,
that,
you know,
the,
the Tutsis were raised up by the European colonials and the Hutus were pushed
down.
So the Hutus had this long history of feeling dehumanized,
disenfranchise.
So yes,
they were acting out of an old,
old rage too.
And there were massacres by Tutsis and Hutus.
Apparently I'm learning now.
Um,
the Armenian genocide is a long story and,
and Armenian genocide is a phrase you can't even say aloud in Turkey.
It's illegal to say in Turkey.
That doesn't mean it didn't happen.
Now Poland is trying to criminalize references to the Polish participation in
the Holocaust.
So I think to end on a note that's complicated,
the worst of us is getting worse.
And I hope that the best of us is getting better.
Thank you for your comment.
Thank you all so much for being here.
I'm going to stick around for awhile if you want to talk.
I think our,
we are,
is our time up.
Um,
we can keep going.
No,
we ended a long time ago.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
As rhe thanks Google.
Thank you all.